how are you can I'm well I'm doing well
so as you are and I are speaking right
now
the status of this Manny Machado move is
what well it is not done until they
issue a press release saying it's done I
have every reason to believe as I
believe last night when I reported that
it's happening that it's still going to
happen but these are the Orioles and I
guess we just have to wait now when you
say that there these are the orals and
we'll just have to wait I did see what
you wrote in the athletic I'm wondering
if you could put a little bit more meat
on the bones for the audience here on
that yeah I just probably should explain
that new relative a history of quashing
trees and crushing free-agent
deals over medical concerns they also
have a history of doing odd things in
trade talks and they're not an easy team
to deal with so it's not surprising that
this would take a little bit longer if
indeed that is the case I have no reason
to believe at this point again that
there is anything else going on but
reviewing the medical doing that kind of
thing but the longer this goes the more
you wonder it's still fairly early in
the day though so we'll see what happens
okay so the deal would be what best you
could tell I don't know exactly my
understanding has been reported by many
people is that a prospect named Houston
Ald as a Cuban health field it would be
the lead piece in the deal coming from
Los Angeles to Baltimore Machado would
go obviously to the Dodgers in place
shortstop it has been reported the oils
will received as many as five prospects
I don't know that I do expect that
there's going to be some money exchanged
if this goes down with the Orioles
sending some money to help the Dodgers
get a little bit more breathing room
under the luxury tax so none of this is
confirmed we'll have to see the exact
details assuming this thing happens but
the Orioles I expect will receive a
pretty impressive package from a chato
considering that he is just under
control for only two plus months more so
I guess then that leads to my next
question is trading him now
I mean is this any better than any deal
but or worse than any deal that they
could have had available to them in the
offseason when when well they're gonna
say no we didn't get as good an offer in
the offseason I don't know what their
exact offers were in the offseason but
if you acquired manny machado in the
offseason you would have gotten from
full season and not just a couple of
months so it would stand to reason that
they had better offers but simply
weren't ready to move at that time yeah
you could even argue should have traded
him long before that but last year they
thought they were going to contend and
that was why did it do it then so this
is the kind of debate that sure they're
fans are going to engage it hey could
we've gotten better and December or
January and we got right here I didn't
want to see what the return ultimately
is before making any kind of assessment
and with prospect trades which you know
this it really difficult to judge in
real time it takes a while before you
really know what's going on MLB Network
Fox Sports the Athletics Ken Rosenthal
here on the Rich Eisen show so what does
it mean also now in this trade for the
Dodgers is there any chance in your mind
that Machado wouldst is more than just a
two-month rental for the Dodgers and
what they would maybe move Seager around
or move Machado around or move Turner
around or just figure out how to keep
them all together
I don't think it's out of the question
that they would try to figure this out
they have to see on the town who
performs for them how the rest of the
season plays out what Kershaw does if he
opted out or not
Machado wants to play shortstop he is
not it was good a defensive shortstop as
Corey Seager at least by the metrics so
things for people suggest that his
metrics or worse than he actually is
that he he does some things that are
better than the numbers show whatever if
he's not willing to go to third base for
the Dodgers or any other team then at
that point they'd have to make a hit and
if the Dodgers wanted a third okay we're
gonna go play shortstop somewhere else
you get the money he'd probably do that
if they still can play short will go
secretive third turn
first Muncey a second do a couple of
other things they make a trailer to
there are all kinds of possibilities
mm-hmm and what was it like in the
dugout last night I was very rare
obviously that you you're you're in a
dugout a and B with a player who has
already been rumored or if not reported
to have been gone and traded and see
where they actually are allowed to have
a phone in their hand to heck
communicate with an agent or a team or
what I mean what was that like Ken
it wasn't quite as dramatic as maybe I
thought it was going to be and I'll
explain a couple of things first during
a game I am NOT normally in a dugout
only in the all-star game right I'm at
the end of the dugout a little cordoned
off area a normal game on the Camberwell
outside the dugout but the all-star game
because it's a different kind of event
this is how it is done and you do we do
interview players during the game and we
do it with live mics on the field and we
do it got reporters like Tom Verducci
and myself so I thought it would be kind
of dramatic in there but it really was
he was just playing the game and I did
get on the boat at one point I saw him
talking to somebody at one point on the
phone the guys all hide their phones
they were videoing each other you might
have heard joke but I can't say at one
point okay
but they got a kick out what they were
doing so that was the way of ways but
the child was very even-handed about
everything he certainly knew what was
going on didn't know details but you of
course he was in the middle of talk
about getting traded and just basically
went out and as he said tried to have as
much fun as you could you know I had the
Commissioner in my studio yesterday can
and asked him about the shifts you know
and and and how it is potentially
degrading offense in baseball and his
appetite for passing a rule for it and
while he said he wasn't gonna get into
rule discussions he you know he was kind
enough to at least delve into this one
he made it seem like he'd like to get
rid of his shift he'd like to figure out
what you know that baseball wall he
doesn't want to get involved in
rules about player positioning man it
just seems like something's got to be
done on this from what do you think
because I know you had two managers in
this all-star game that loved it
and would a JH I asked point-blank on
this show about a month ago and he said
he would not be happy with any rules
passed to get rid of the shift what are
things stand in your mind from from your
position again I don't know that I would
say Manfred wants to get rid of the
shift I would say he is certainly open
to discussing ways to make the game
better and that's an all-encompassing
look and people say our big deal the
game is fine I don't know that the game
is fine the game has become a homerun
strikeout Walk fest and the game has
basically turned into an analytics
driven device to be as efficient as
possible if you are the general manager
or manager of a baseball team and your
ape lamenting these things you are doing
exactly the right thing because you're
trying to win trying to win is not the
same as putting out a good entertainment
product and while yesterday's game last
night's game was entertaining in a sense
with all the home runs ten of them no I
liked triples I like double now of all
these things now to get back to your
question get rid of ships would be a
dramatic step but there are lesser steps
that you could take maybe forcing all
infielders to stay on the dirt that
would be one way to do it keep your feet
on the dirt or one foot of the dirt so
you're not playing short right field
taking hits away like that those are
things that I would expect would get
more consideration and perhaps an
outright ban of ships I don't know that
that's healthy but at the same time
everyone expected the hitters to adjust
although adjust the game is organic we
just guessed inflows no hit about 10
years now it has been adjusted and the
hitters have not adjusted so that's why
they've got to look closer so last one
for you Ken Rosenthal they were assuming
I'm assuming I guess the last two one
Machado took off a Baltimore as uniform
for the last
last night correct form again okay yeah
and then the so now who's next who's a
big name what he got for me with the
trade deadline two weeks away and so our
teams but no one in the industry
seriously thinks he's going to get
traded after that it's not a great group
of players to be perfectly honest that
are available it's kind of mediocre
names average players j-hat Prince it's
a good example now he was an all-star he
was the Blue Jays all stories a good
left-handed pitcher is he Cliff Lee from
a few years back now he's not that guy
so that is kind of what we're looking at
every year at the deadline we get our
head spun we get turned around things
happen that no one anticipated or
predicted so I would expect it's going
to be active it's always active and I
would expect we're going to be surprised
by at least one name simply because of
the history of the trade deadline that
is generally what happened Ken
appreciate the time thanks for calling I
know you probably just got off a plane
back here from DC to be on MLB Network
all day so thanks to the call appreciate
it you gotta that's Ken Rosenthal at can
underscore Rosenthal on Twitter Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience